my producer is telling me right now that
you like the ads that we do yeah yeah I
love the the episodes oops or ads I love
that because you know here in Slovenia
and we don't hear your ads wait why
don't you guys hear the ads the ads are
fun not all of them but we'll try to
make them fun Adam Adam our grand Guru
is here Adam explain why they're not
hearing the ads in Slovenia the dynamic
ad insertion technology
oh my God he literally is wearing a
t-shirt that says the man
[Music]
I didn't even want to say that but they
do have uh like Geo targets and Geo
blockers and it ends up that a lot of
international users that was the whole
reason we did the upsell ads was so that
the international people uh like Simon
could could hear the ads you know what I
bet if I started mentioning uh a lot of
um Slovenian products and businesses in
Slovenia wouldn't
the dynamic robot that inserts the ads
start to drop them in presumably yeah I
don't know exactly how the technology
works but it sounds like yeah that would
make it work I think that's what we
should be doing don't you Simon
sure no I mean if we start devoting a
chunk of our show Fairly regularly to
Slovenia I think we're gonna crack that
market yeah yeah we're gonna get all 15
people in Slovenia
uh really excited they'll be so excited
they'll run from one end of the country
to the other in three minutes
[Laughter]
the whole business that you want me to
promote on the podcast in Slovenia yep
beside our company obviously yeah screw
them that sounds too serious I mean like
a place that you go regularly that's a
regular part of your day so I I also
enjoy coffee very much I have at least
five coffees a day or two five oh my God
I mean yeah so you spend at least half
your life urinating that's fantastic
the trick is not to have not to drink
water just coffee and then you don't
have that problem
well you've tried another great life
attack from Simon and Slovenia
so just coffee you drink coffee right
well where do you get your coffee is
there a local place you go yeah I love
this local Roasters and they're called
stove coffee roasters they Rose their
own coffee no coffee roasters huh yeah
and what's so great about them I mean
they are they have a great coffee of
course it's freshly roasted they they
know how to prepare good coffee and and
I mean they're just great what about the
service it stows I'm trying to get as
much information as I can to help with
my promotion of Stowe's coffee shop in
Slovenia is it stows coffee roasters is
that it
yeah yeah because they also Rose their
own coffee and where are they located
what's the address what street are they
on yeah I'm not sure about the street
they are located in our capital city in
Ljubljana
yeah and you know say Luby is it
Ljubljana is it close enough you tell me
how to pronounce it correctly okay
no no it starts with
Ljubljana yeah close enough closer this
is frustrating I don't know he says it
starts with LJ so it sounds like he's
saying
what am I doing wrong you keep saying it
starts with an l l j l
jubiana
okay you say it one more time Simon and
then I'm gonna commit suicide go ahead
yeah so it's Ljubljana Ljubljana I'm
just gonna mush it up I'm gonna say it
really quickly we'll get through it okay
and I think how's the service there is
there anyone there you've struck up a
friendship with is there anyone there
who's who's oh he's oh he's the best ask
for you know yeah no I I don't know them
by name but uh they are they're all
great their service is great so give me
one little detail about the place okay
this is a this is a funny detail they
are located under the museum and it
sounds strange but it's not uh and this
is a really uh hipster kind of place and
and what kind of museum is that is it
the Museum of all things Slovenia yeah
okay terrific yeah all right uh let's
get the word out I think okay we should
do this right now I think so another way
for it to go after is uh is is you help
feed me okay um so now what do I love to
drink more than anything else in the
world why no oh I'm sorry
ask me again no we're going with that
okay that's true yeah but when I've had
way too much wine how do I like to sober
up what do I drink oh you drink coffee
you better drink coffee I love
well-roasted coffee and the only place I
like to get my coffee is in Slovenia
they kill it uh -huh I've got a private
private jet fueled up on a Runway right
outside my house you know this I do yes
yeah I am in big trouble it's I have a
huge carbon footprint very expensive and
whenever I want a cup of coffee I hop on
that jet and I Jet right to Slovenia to
their Capital Louisiana
oh they're great they're fantastic man
that coffee is good the service is
impeccable yeah it's kind of a hipster
joint but I love hipsters and guess what
I love where it's located where is it
under the Museum oh the museum yeah well
it's Slovenia so they only call it the
museum
going to the museum and also the the
museum is where they once featured a
statue of Donald Trump oh yeah it was it
was up for 48 hours
and then it was they took it out into a
field and hit it with sticks yeah look
all my Slovenian Pals whether it's uh uh
Luca doncic from uh from the from the
NBA yeah uh or uh Melania Trump right I
hook up with them when I'm there getting
coffee yeah they you guys all the three
of you go together we go together and
then we we grab a cup of coffee we check
out the museum and we see all of the
great works of art in Slovenia and then
uh it's really nice we take about a 10
minute stroll which takes us around the
circumference of Slovenia so check it
out ladies and gentlemen if you've got a
private jet on the go outside your house
make sure you get to Stowe's Coffee
Roasters in in which city
and I had a small stroke there
located under the museum
and you'll get the best coffee you've
had in your life and don't just take it
from me take it from my pal Simon and
then Simon you say a quick thing quick
thing
all right well Simon you just we just
made a really good ad for your coffee
shop you better get free coffee there
from now on I hope so I hope so wait
till you go in there and tell them
there's this guy named Conan O'Brien
and after your two-hour explanation and
showing them a couple of hours worth of
YouTube videos and playing them maybe
six hours of the podcast uh you'll get a
free cup of coffee